Hello and welcome.
Thank you all for joining us for another
iteration of authors at Google where we
are very pleased to welcome Cindy Padua.
I hope actually I pronounced that right.
It fell to ask. Okay. Um,
so in recent months we've had the good
fortune here to host many leading lights.
Uh, you know, we had, uh,
a Barney frank and more
recently David Duchovny,
but today's guest puts all of
those to shame. Uh, we're, uh,
happy to have a pre pre eminent
scholar of the Victorian computing era,
uh, among us a Sydney Pedro
who hails from Canada,
did her, uh, her schoolwork at, uh,
University of Alberta where she got
a phd apparently in footnotes. Um,
and has a sense become both an impressive
comic artists in a impressive scholar
of the history of early computing.
Um, and as I was just saying to her,
I'm very glad that she reads all the
primary source materials so that I don't
have to,
uh,
because there's quite a copious amount
of it and I am truly impressed by the
depth to which she has, uh,
she has explored it. Uh,
so I guess without further ado,
we'll welcome Sydney to tell us all
about Lovelace and Babbage and marvelous
history of computing.
Ah, thanks. Hi. Um, my
name is Sydney Padua.
Uh, I don't have a phd, I
should hasten to say, um,
I'm actually, uh, so this is me.
I am just a random cartoonist,
uh,
and also a VFX artists.
Um, most of the time I,
um, uh, can be found, uh,
making imaginary monsters appear to
attack people for the movies. Um,
I,
um,
came from hand drawn animation many
years ago I worked on iron giant,
which I'm just filling a lot
of people really like. Uh, um,
since then I've moved on
to, uh, computers where, um,
apparently I work on
blue and orange movies.
Um, when I have to say
it's, it's really, um, uh,
very strange and hilarious.
In five years ago,
if you told me I would be giving
a talk on computers at Google a,
I would have laughed in your
face because I was a very,
very reluctant convert a to computer
animation. Um, I've always, uh,
distracted dysplastic
computers. Um, I was, uh,
probably the last person to
be dragged backwards, uh,
with my finger nails
digging into the carpet, uh,
into CG from hand drawn
animation. Um, but, uh,
the reason I'm here is because
of these two crazy kids. Um,
so that, so eight Ada, this
and Charles Babbage. Um,
I think a lot of people know their
story roughly from computer science 101.
You kind of get the quick rundown.
Um,
Charles Babbage occasion professor
of mathematics at Cambridge, um,
the position once held by
Newton and currently held I
believe by Stephen Hawking.
Um, so he's pretty clever. Um, he, uh,
was famous in his own time for, uh,
this mysterious calculating machine,
which was perpetually
planned and never built, um,
which we would never recognize as a
computer. And it is really amazing.
Their computer, as I'll talk about a
bit later. Um, the other person in that,
uh, duo is, um, it'll Lovelace.
She was born eight Gordon,
uh, probably better known as eight, eight,
a Gordon Daughter of George Gordon,
better known as Lord Byron,
the infamous poet. Um, I personally,
I learned about these people,
um, when I was in a pub in
London with a friend of mine,
Sue Sherman Anderson, who started
this thing called Ada Lovelace day,
which you might be familiar with.
Um,
it's a sort of an online blogging
festival every year to celebrate women in
computing and raise their profile.
Um, and she said to me, Sydney, here,
a woman in tech, now you should do a
blog post rate all of these day. Um,
and I said,
I don't even know who I love lists is.
I'm also not really a woman in
tech. I work on tech in tech. Um,
but I went to Wikipedia like
anybody else would. And uh,
there are found this extraordinary story,
um,
about Lovelace who,
uh,
was raised by mathematicians so that she
would not become a crazy poet like her
father. And it had this very much a feel
of a superhero origin story. You know,
it had had that Nice angsty
backstory, um, conflict, uh, oh,
that would make a really
cute little comic.
And I thought because
I didn't know who love,
I suppose that I should probably a nice
idea for blog posts would just be a
short little comic. I did it. And as a
strip, so it's like it's about this long.
Um, just explaining where had a lovely
says and I did it like this. Um,
so yeah, I mean this is all true. Um,
I can now verify having read a hell
of a lot of letters. I'm sorry.
Heck of a lot of letters. Um, that, uh,
lovely says mother was very
concerned that she become,
that should not become poetical.
Um,
which I believe was a Victorian
euphemism for not lady like or wild.
Um,
so she had a tutored in
mathematics and logic. Um,
she met Babbage at a party in 1833.
How is the best place to meet someone?
And he's leaning there on
the only working fragment.
I'm a machine that he built, um, that's
a fragment of the difference engine,
which was a calculator. Um, you can
actually see that I that a piece,
a beautiful machine, um, made of
brass in the science museum in London.
It's about this big, and you could
turn a crank and it could turn out, uh,
you know, some little
calculations. Um, at this party,
apparently someone said a,
as everyone gazed upon the machine,
like savages looking at or looking glass,
only eight of Byron understood the true
beauty of the machine and understand its
function. Um, she sort
hanging out with Babbage, um,
for a while she became very fascinated
with this machine and in fact obsessed
with analytical engine. Um, and uh,
wrote of course a famous paper about it,
which I'll talk about it in a bit.
I'm having, this was a very short comic.
I should stress the original comic, uh,
was maybe four pages long laid out.
And of course I reached the end,
which is a really stupid ending.
That beverage doesn't build this machine
and a lovely sties at 36 and it's a
hundred years before there's another
computer. So this was a real dead end,
unfortunately in computing history.
Um,
and I think I knocked this whole
comic out in an evening. Um,
and when I reached this panel, it
was about midnight and I thought, oh,
I can't end it like that. Um,
you know, that's terrible.
So I just throw in as
a joke, this panel. Um,
I think I was aware of steam
punk as a thing that existed. Um,
so I just kind of threw them in fabulous
clothes and gave them ray guns and sort
of resurrected them
briefly as a punchline. Um,
I think I was thinking of the Avengers,
it's uncanny
the,
so I kind of put their through their comic
up online on my blog and went to bed.
And then when I woke up this and the next
morning it was turning up all over the
internet as this person is going to do a
comic in which Ada Lovelace and Charles
Babbage fight crime. It was a joke. Um,
I succumb easily to peer pressure
and also I was putting off working on
something else. Um, so I started
drawing comics about, hey,
lovely son Charles Babbage fighting crime.
Um,
anyone who's read the comic will tell
you this is a very sporadic, uh, comic.
Um, uh, they fight crime.
They find it quite badly.
Um,
it's quite a silly comic.
I should stress anyone expecting a very
serious comic about Victorian competing
is going to be out of luck
because it's quite silly. Um,
especially because their chief enemies
of course as they were in life are poetry
and street music, which choice beverages,
famous bugbear was, uh, was street music.
So that's kind of his main
nemesis is the organist
aside from silly comics.
If you look at the book,
you'll notice there's quite a
lot of words in it for a comic.
This is because as I was
doing the blog, um, I,
um,
I became very obsessed with reading kind
of all the wonderful primary documents
that were turning up online.
Um,
in a sense the footnotes are a
joke on lovely. His famous paper,
which you can see on Google books.
This is it. As it originally appeared.
Um, loveless wrote her paper
at it again as a translation.
Um,
Babbage himself never wrote,
never published anything on his own,
a machine or anything in detail.
And of course,
women did not normally
publish scientific papers.
This was not something
that was done. Um, however,
there was a space for
women to do translations.
It says a sort of a lady like
accomplishment. Um, so when this paper,
this is Minna Braya, um, a guy,
he eventually became prime minister
of Italy at the time he was a guy, um,
at a conference where Babish spoken,
described his machine,
Middlebury took notes, he
published the notes in French. Um,
a year later Lovelace translated the notes
from the French into the English. Um,
and again,
adding footnotes because actually right
along and she herself was considered an
expert on Babbage's machine at
this time. Um, mostly by, um,
hanging out and continually begging
him for their plans. Um, uh,
so she was known as someone
who knew a lot about it.
That's why she was asked to
translate the paper. Um, but,
um, as she kind of went down
the translation, she began
to add footnotes saying,
oh, actually I have a much clearer
illustration of this. Or in fact, um,
you know, another way to say
this is this, um, are a lot,
I think to some extent she is actually
writing the footnotes to Babbage because
she often says things like,
I don't know if this has occurred to
the creator of the calculating machine,
but I have this drink, their idea
about how this could actually work.
Um, and this is one of those
notes where she says, um,
this is the first appearance of general
computing theory in enabling the
mechanism to combine together general
symbols in successes of unlimited variety
and extent. The United link is,
and she goes on, she's Victorian.
So these sentences get extremely lengthy.
Um,
if you battle your way through this paper,
you'll see it's not the most
readable thing in the world,
but it is wonderful and it
can be found on Google books,
which is my favorite thing in the world.
And which is why I'm so delighted
always to speak to Google because I'm,
this entire comic would not have been
possible without the incredible Cornucopia
of amazing documents that were poured out.
Uh,
right around 2009 whenever
down the comic, um, uh,
Google books was dumping
basically all this, uh,
19th century FEMARA online. And so, um,
I should stress, again, I'm not a proper
scholar, I am just some random clown,
but the great power there will
books is that, um, uh, I'm not,
I don't have to go through some specific
place in an archive and know him and
I'm looking for, I can just
type yeah. Babin street music,
1839 to 70 and you would get
amazing amounts of stuff.
Um, this is what it looks like
in situ. Great. Kat. I agree.
Calculator and it does have the
famous problem solver. Babbage. Um,
I think the first thing I
was surprised define when I
started, um, my research, uh,
was how famous Babbage was. Um, this is
actually from the Salt Lake City News.
Um,
and Babbage was famous enough that fed
the Salt Lake City news would run like a
kind of some random anecdotes about him.
I also,
I like this because of the pockets.
Cigar case free to smoke
because if times it's fun. Um,
this is a great set of anecdotes.
This is in the book. Um,
I believe in this actually. Um, they've
come some lovely stuff in the end.
I think she says,
um,
our family is an alternate stratification
of poetry in mathematics. Uh,
along the line there.
Um,
also to get a sense of the Victorian era.
A clever woman is one who's abilities
never unpleasantly fountain by the rest of
the world. Um, so yeah,
I found just fantastic stuff.
Oh,
he's calculating machine was an endless
subject of monologue mode of people
remark on beverages, tendency to go on
and on about his calculating machine.
Um, what else? Uh, of course it wasn't
only Google that I found stuff in.
This is, I'm the general method
of my approaching the comics,
whereas I would run around and meet
a bunch of primary documents and a,
and then just riff on it
basically on a comic. Um,
this is from when Queen Victoria's
diaries were digitized and put online. So,
of course immediately searched Babbage,
um,
who was by the way very obsessed with
what other people thought about him.
He used to keep a scrapbook with
all of his news clippings in it. Uh,
this, this is a classic
Babbage quotation Lord Damn,
that's Lord Melbourne has said beverage
has made a great full of himself as he
does everywhere. Uh, parole
beverage. Um, he was,
he had many, many fantastic
talents, but um, uh,
he did have some issues
socializing properly with people.
Um, so that's Queen Victoria
on Charles Babbage. Um,
this is Babbage's punch a
on the great exhibition.
He's very angry at only being honorable.
We mentioned is that all scandalous,
uh,
to go into the great exhibition of 1851.
Um,
he was very angry that they didn't
put his calculating machine in there.
I think the feeling was that it, uh, that
people would not understand what it was.
Um, which I think shows a sad, uh,
underestimation of the British public.
I think people would have
thought it was great. Um,
I like this one beverage to the
logger with medical Frankenstein.
That's from Google books.
Um,
I tod is a ton of primary
documents, a in a, in the book.
I'm probably too many apparently. Um, uh,
this is 1833,
the New York Mirror oh five.
You need good eyes to
read this one oh five.
It is said that eight of Byron
sole daughter of a Nobel Bard.
It's the most course and
vulgar woman in England, uh,
which I do have her swear
a fair bit.
So that's sourced. Uh, anyone's,
anyone's dubious about the
historical accuracy of, uh, at,
you'll notice these, these wrong
coverups here that is also source.
Faberge did in fact invented an error
pop up for the analytical engine.
Um,
believe it or not,
if any mistake had been made by
the attendant and the wrong law,
the rear of them had been accidentally
given to the engine at the proper place
of ca plate above the raw, the rhythm
with the word wrong engraved on it.
He later as the continually
ringing round loud bell,
which I'm sure would be
absolutely delightful if you
were the attendant trying
to hunt down this error
in this gigantic machine.
So this is Lovelace debugging a,
one of these error popups
here with a crow bar,
which is the only way you can
debug the analytical engine.
Um, yeah, so, so this is
just my joke on the subject.
Let's see. Our Lady Lovelace's
getting on some cartoons squares,
but I want to say because
this is being recorded, uh,
that's a special language we're
developing just for the engine. Um,
so amongst anything Babbage's Lovelace,
we're actually both very funny people.
People tended to remark on them as being
eccentric and tell stories about how
strange they were. But amongst all
the wonderful things in Google books,
this is by far my favorite.
This was a really magical find that
would only have been possible with Google
books because this is from a
thing called the southern review,
which was this short live journal
out of, I believe Maryland. Um,
it's,
it was put out in 1867 this is from a,
to celebrate the culture of the south
and the wake of the civil war. Um, any,
what we'd like is a church circular.
It's clippings from all sorts of
random stuff happening around Maryland.
Generally speaking,
uh, but one of them is,
is basically your basic letter home to
the folks from the guy who took a trip to
Europe. Um, uh,
this is Walter Reed who's a
wonderful writer by the way.
He was actually from Pennsylvania,
a English professor there and he writes
by far the most vivid description of
Babbage, um, that I found from the period.
This is actually a letter from
1854. Um, I don't know why they,
I guess they had some space to fill
in the old southern review, uh,
10 years later, cause I'm a, I'm
not quite sure why they put it in.
They put it in the entire letter,
which is about 13 pages long. Um,
and he meets a several people,
but one of them is Babbage. Um,
and there's just a magical section.
This is about two years after love,
they said died.
Um,
and we get here after he got up to
go by some chance of conversation.
The late lady Lovelace's name, Lord
Byron Starter, Ada was mentioned.
He knew her intimately and spoke highly
of her mathematical powers and ever
peculiar capability higher. He said
the, that of anyone he knew to prepare,
I believe it was the
descriptions connected with is
calculating machine. I fear,
I'm not expressing myself rightly here
as to the precise nature of the subject.
Um, and I think he's talking
about the programs here. Um,
the descriptions of how the
machine would go through a problem.
Um, so this is, um, uh,
this is something that would not have
been found without Google search.
Basically.
If you were Babbage scholar,
I can't see any conceivable reason you
would be reading through every single
issue or the southern review.
1867. Um, so yeah, thank you.
Google. Um, it's a, it's a,
it's just a magical thing.
Um, so, um, the other kind
of stream of research I took,
um, was regarding the
analytical engine. Um,
in addition to all these ideas,
all these wonderful primary documents
that were extremely evocative of beverage
and lovely says people. They're
extremely vivid personalities. Um,
and they write all their
own material and they have,
they come up with great gags for
themselves and great dialogue. Um,
but there's sort of a third character
in the comic and that was always the
analytical engine. Um, as I said,
I'm not a computer person. Um,
I, uh, um, so for me when I
tended to draw the engine,
it's this vast building
sized labyrinth of confusion.
Um, people tend to get lost
and attacked in it. But, uh,
I guess as I guess I was
drawing the comic, I began, um,
gain being really frustrated by the
fact that I'm pretty much every book,
even fairly specialists
books on the engine. Uh,
would a say it was exactly
like a modern computer,
but it's too complicated for
you to understand it. Um,
and also they wouldn't give
me a drawing of the engine,
which I'm really as a comic artists.
I wanted to see a drawing of a huge ash,
huge ass engine made of, made of cogs.
Um, you know, it's just eye candy.
So, um, uh,
I had to actually make one myself so you
can get a sense of what this engine was.
Um, a lot of you are familiar. Sorry.
This is my own video and I know I
shot it like a newb in portrait. Um,
so this is the beautiful, uh, let me know,
turn on the sound
difference engine. Um, but they
still in mountain view California.
It's has then demonstrating it for me,
which is just wonderful of them.
You can hate me
like an idiot over it.
Beautiful arms of the
backer carrying the ones.
Um,
so that's the difference engine,
huge machine and it's incredibly
beautiful and incredibly clever.
But that's not the analytical
Andrea. Um, there's tons of damage.
The difference engine and the
analytical engine, um, the, uh,
different centers is essentially an
adder. Uh, it, it really only has,
it hasn't a very specific
way and a very clever way,
but it can only add, um,
right around the 1830s,
early 1830s, um, pretty much
one Babbage met love these. Um,
he, uh, he began to think,
what if you could take the,
some that came out of one
end of the engine and put it
back in the other end. Um,
he described this as the
engine eating its own tail. Um,
so he devised a second machine,
uh, the analytical engine.
Um, he, they didn't
build either of them. Um,
partly because, um, it's
just really super hard.
I think a lot of people ask me,
you know,
why didn't Babbage build the analytical
engine? It's actually really, really,
really hard to build a giant
computer entirely made of cogs.
It's not a disgrace not to complete it.
Um,
Babbage also kept changing the plans.
Um, so this is the famous, um, plan 25,
um, it's the most beautiful and
the most complete baptist plans.
This is from 1840. So this is the machine
that lovelies would have been writing,
uh, her paper about. Um, so I,
I mean at first as you know,
a comic artist who is not very clever,
I left at this picture and said,
Ooh, and then I said, I have no
idea what I'm looking at here. Um,
so in order to draw the
machine, um, accurately,
I had to basically go in and start doing
elevations and hunt down as many of
Babbage's, um, diagrams as I could. Um,
it was by no means straight forward,
um,
to do an image of this.
Um,
partly because I'm Babish wasn't
very good at, at, at, at, at,
at showing complete elevations.
Um, so this is very much a,
an interpretation of me. But, uh, anyway,
this is possibly the first,
um,
visualization of the entire engine.
MMM.
You may go, Ooh, because it
took me forever. Thank you.
Thank you very much.
There's the punch cards at the bottom.
I'll actually show you I'm in animation.
Um, how I believe it works because it's
much clearer. There's a lot going on.
Basically you have storage,
uh, going down the back here,
this is a whole line of
gears. Um, for Babish,
this machine was pretty much acts,
I mean exclusively and
machine for doing arithmetic.
The entire bulk of this
thing, um, is numerical.
So these columns,
each of these columns represents a
number with 50 decimal places. Um,
so each little gear has a number
from one to 10. It's decimal a on it.
So you set this to five, this to two,
and then you have 25. There's two, three.
You have 325 so it just goes up.
And so if you have a column of 50 gears,
it's a column of,
of number of 50 decimal places.
Um, 50 is a lot of decimal basis.
Um,
uh,
Babbage said himself that the reason he
does put in so many is that he thought
that should be sufficient for all
future purposes of science. Um,
so that's uh, that's beverage all
over for you. So here's the, um,
the three types of punch cards they'll
go through in a bit barrels. Um,
I should say,
um,
I think the machine was probably actually
a bit taller than this cat's for scale.
Um, I think also it's very unlikely
it could have been free standing.
I think you would have to have
in mash the entire thing, uh,
in an enormous cage to keep it stable.
The whole machine is based around,
um,
little miracle gears that turn around
and they have locks to hold it in place.
And if the lock hits a tooth at
any point in this gigantic machine,
the whole thing, we'll freeze. Um,
so absolutely nothing can be out of
alignment by so much as a couple of
millimeters. So stability would be a
big, big, big issue with this machine.
Although that said the difference
engine works on that same principle and
generally speaking it, it's
hardly ever crashes ever. So
okay.
No, they think that only 20. So,
um, but yeah, you have a few more,
a little more space for error
in those. Um, right. So,
uh, that's the analytical engine. Um,
so in the book without the power
of animation, this is the plan.
I did a, it's actually
quite a bit more clear, um,
in animation. Um, I had
a great advantage, uh,
in building these diagrams in
that I am a computer animator,
so I work on this thing all day long.
Um,
so this is a simplification.
This is sort of a card,
cartoon engine version.
It's stripped down, um,
partly because it's really difficult
to see what's going on. Uh,
when you have the whole thing in.
And also it's so huge sea of hopefully
labeled the layer whole thing.
It's so huge.
My machine really starts to struggle
once you put in all those gears.
Um,
but it's just decimal places.
So this is actually just a slice and
each slice going up is exactly the same.
So you don't need all those 15
understand that the information flow.
So here's your engine. I'm assuming you
guys are interested in this because,
uh, some people start to glaze over,
but I thought Google would probably,
uh, so, okay. Just so I can explain here.
Basically the ranch colors indicate
the driver and the Greens are passing,
um, as, um, these,
so the first thing that activates is
the number card and that will be a card
with each 50 decimal number in, in holes
basically, or rather a lack of holes.
The way these punch card things work,
if there's a whole,
so you'll have a whole
arrangement of leavers each
lined up to all the holes. Um,
you'll have a whole pretty much everywhere
except for one point. So as the,
as the card is po pushed her over
the leavers, if there's holes,
it just goes right through and nothing
happens. But if there's no hole,
then the card will push the lever
at that corresponding position.
So that's how the punch cards work.
Um,
so that will basically select
a bunch of leavers. 50 of them.
I haven't animated 50 cause I
was just way too much work. Um,
and that sends it to an address on the
story. The address is on the card as well.
Um,
Babbitt has an address thing system.
The machine is an incredibly beautiful
and incredibly clever thing and really
shockingly like a computer.
Um, this is the store. Um,
this is short.
Like the store would have gone on into
the distance on Babbage said maybe a
hundred, maybe a thousand, maybe 5,000.
Um, everyone wants more storage. Obviously
you'd run into a problem because the,
the entire way that these read, so okay,
so Reese one number onto the store and
then reads the second number onto the
store.
So that's the two storage positions.
Um, now this is the,
um, the operations card.
I should say I'm slightly fuzzy
as to the order of events.
I think the operation card is next,
but it might be the address,
but it doesn't actually matter. Um, the
operations cards are amazingly clever.
He single hole, they were quite
small cards. A single hole, um,
would then rotate these
barrels to certain position.
There's actually three sets of barrels
and each of the barrels has 50 or 80 Rosa
pegs around.
Um,
so a single hole and an operations card
could activate dozens and dozens of
leavers, which is what you
need to run an operation. Um,
the machine could do basically four
things. It could add, subtract, multiply,
divide.
Any more complicated
mathematical thing you did,
you would have to be very clever
in the programming end. Uh,
break it down into those four operations,
run it down a string
of cards. Um, but it's,
um,
so all those leaders are activated and
what they do is they then engage all the
leavers, um, at one of these sections.
Basically each of these little sections,
this is just a cartoon version.
All these little sections are beautifully
worked out in extremely complicated,
but each of these little
sections does a specific thing.
I'm adding or caring the ones,
or if you were multiplying a number,
it would break it up into multiplied
by one, multiplied by two,
multiplied by three in
Charlie's sections for speed.
So it basically engages that section.
So it's already to go.
Then the variable cards,
which is the third kind of card.
Okay.
Um, this is the addressing system
basically. Uh, it then says, okay,
pick up from address number
one engages the rack,
the rack slides off into what you
call the ingress access, which is a,
this one at the front
here. So this is, sorry,
I'm pointing when she can't see.
So this is the position in the store.
So it actively reads out to
the passive ingress anxious,
then that engages the big central.
We'll possibly,
I mean this is all much
more complicated actually.
There's a way more bits
then I'm showing here. Um,
and then this becomes
active and reads the,
know the number off into whatever
section has been indicated.
Reads the second number.
So now ascot,
both numbers and then it does a thing.
Basically
each of these little bits is very,
very specialized for specific, um,
uh, arithmetical thing. Um, you'll notice
the, the barrels are turning around.
The barrel would have, uh, basically
a little program in wedges around.
So once you set it up
with one operations card,
then it runs through a
little micro program.
That's my scientific sound fit to
that it would make. So once it's done,
hooks back up so that now it's ready
to go, the number is processed.
So it's taken those two numbers.
It can only work on two numbers
at a time and spit out a result.
So it takes that number hooks up to the
output and the output hooks up to the
variable card to take the address
that it's supposed to read out to
and then reads out.
So now that you have the results on the
store, um, and that will animate Trey,
now you understand how
everything's going on.
I would take, I mean, it runs in cycles
like a computer. They're just way, way,
way slower. Um, uh, uh,
multiplication might take a few minutes
to run because it's got to go through,
over and over again. Um, but, um,
I don't know much about computers.
I probably know more about the
analytical engine and how it works.
Then our computer and how it works, but
it's, um, it is remarkably computer like,
and it's incredibly detailed.
I mean, Babbage left,
this is not an abstract concept.
Babbage left extremely detailed
plans for all these leavers.
He thought through all
the timing, um, you know,
all the weights and all that
stuff. Um, and there was in fact,
I should give a plug to plan 28, uh,
if you go to plan 20 eight.org, um,
there's some crazy folks who are trying
to get one built, uh, in reality,
like they built the difference engine.
Um, so yeah, that's the analytical,
the analytical engine and a bunch of
primary documents and my comic and the,
that's it.
MMM.
I think we have a few minutes for
questions if anyone has any questions.
All right.
So you said there would be one layer of
these for every digit of the 50 digits.
Okay. Um, do you know how like the
carry system where between layers?
Yes. Um, I,
it's actually,
I put a video on youtube up and it took
me nine minutes to explain the adult.
I know that I go engine
Carrie. Um, it's uh,
yeah,
yeah. If you go to eat, I
guess I could put it on,
I could either explain it to
bring up that file and explain it.
He basically uses like a very,
very ingenious, um, system.
Um, the, the carry arms,
the spiral ones that go up the
back of the difference engine,
Babbage discarded those
cause they were too slow.
They cost like 10 imaginary seconds
off his imaginary machine. Um,
so he,
he devised,
and this was by far his favorite part
of the engine was the ones mechanisms.
So he would be absolutely thrilled that
someone was asking that question because
he goes in his autobiography,
he says,
this is by far the most
important part of the engine.
This is in the system for carrying the
ones. Um, basically he had a little peg,
uh, on the nine, on each, um, gear. Um,
so as it came around, if there was
a peg, it's really hard to explain.
Uh, if there's a peg and
a peg below for Carrie,
it would lift to carries,
um,
kind of onto the next gear. It's super
hard to explain, but if you come up after,
I'll show you the animation. Um, and
everyone who is intimate can see it.
Just probably everybody
actually. But it, it,
it does take a while to explain cause
it's, it's quite fiddly. But yeah,
he had it all worked out for sure.
You may have implied an answer
to this question, but did you,
it sounds like you do have youtube videos
with things like this and explaining
all the parts as well.
Yeah, I've got a couple. Um, uh, um,
the carry one is the most complete.
I haven't done this one.
I'll put up shortly with an explanation
because I just have the animation with
no explanation now. But, Yep.
Thank you.
Alright,
so you said that the operations that
could do to the four sort of fundamental
arithmetic operations, it
actually divides. Yes. Wow.
Cause Division division is Ma is sort
of arithmetically a far more complicated
operation to do and like modern CPS
devote an inordinate number of transistors
to division alone. So how, how
does, how has division implemented?
You're asking me to do this.
Okay.
I'd actually, division is the one I'm
Phaziah Stan, I haven't built it yet.
Basically it's unwinding it,
if that makes sense. Right. Um,
so to multiply it's winding around
and around has got accumulators and,
and to divide it unwinds by the divisor,
it breaks up the divisor into units
and then unwinds it unit by unit.
It's quite complicated and it's very
like everything Fabish it's very,
very clever, but quite kind
of Rube Goldberg Goldberg in
it seems like you could just go
through and stamp on every part.
This is part is quite,
yeah.
Oh,
he was so clever.
So it lovely. Stay mostly
wrote programs for this device.
Did,
were her program strictly mathematical,
like she kept getting logarithms and
that's your thing or did she do, did,
was there any approach towards
the more general, uh, computation?
I'm loving this. This paper has,
there's a bunch of programs. Um,
most,
most of them are quite short and we're
sort of Babbage's little tiny workouts.
There's a huge fold out. One,
the Bernoulli Bernoulli numbers,
one that kind of
demonstrates all the loops.
This machine can loop by the way it can
instruct itself to go background. Um,
her, those programs are all
strictly mathematical. Um,
and Babbage for sure
only saw the machine as,
as for doing specifically arithmetic.
Um,
so no mine craft,
no. Um, but, um,
Lovelace had actually looked
at the machine and said,
um, I mean it was lovely. I select
in the machine and said, actually,
um, with the new developments in logic,
this is before boob by about 10 years.
But, um, she was a student of
Augustus to Morgan, who was,
I'm trying to find this
way of mathematizing logic.
Um, so she looked at it,
said, you know, with these
leavers and pigs, um,
you could in theory turned
this into a logic machine, uh,
not an arithmetic machine. And her
example was, um, was music theory,
which is probably way in advance.
Um, but she said if you could,
maybe you could take the
rules of music theory. Um,
and find a way to express them.
She didn't use the word program,
but into a set of rules for the
machine. The machine could, in theory,
compose music, uh, scientific
music. She said if any extent.
Um, but no, we don't have any, um,
uh, unfortunately any experiments
in that direction from her. Um,
and I think it would like,
you would to actually do that
sort of thing with a machine,
you'd have to redesign the whole thing
because they enormous bulk of it is
really, really very, very specialized
to, to Earth medical bits.
So, um, hey, I'm really, um, anyway,
but the extent to which you got a,
you're heading into the
workings of this machine.
I also expect you got your head into the
workings of Charles Babbage and it'll
Lovelace personally. Can you talk
to me a little bit about sort of,
um,
how,
how you came to grips with what
motivates them as people and, um, how,
or to what extent you sort of personally
identified with them and it's in
process of doing all the work?
Um, I think for, for, um,
oh,
they were both definitely
became incredibly absorbed, uh,
with,
uh,
with this machine and what it could do.
Um,
in terms of what drove them, it's, um,
okay.
I don't know. It's hard to
say. I mean, I think once,
once you see how it could work,
you know,
especially if you're Charles Babbage
with this brain that can see all these
possibilities, uh, and the, and
that can see the machine, I mean,
I guess what you'd call a
spacial reasoning skills
must have been remarkable.
Um,
it drove him nuts that he said that
that's something you could see so clearly
wasn't actually happening.
So he became obsessed with solving all
the problems and he kept solving the
problems.
You know,
past the point that the problems were
so many decades away from existing.
You're like, Babbage, stop. I had the
carry, I mean, the carry mechanism is, uh,
is classic Babbage and that he had a
carry mechanism design that works the
difference engine one, but if it was too
slow, you know, I'd have to look ahead.
Uh, I mean it couldn't look ahead and
had to kind of feel out one at a time.
And he spent a year,
he says in his autobiography,
he spent an entire year shaving these
imaginary seconds off of this machine.
Um,
so for him it was definitely solving all
these problems and getting the perfect
machine, um, for love,
nice cheese, you know, as,
as always she's a lot murkier and more
complicated in shit. And the comic,
she's can be the Batman
ask, you know, kind of, uh,
angst-ridden one. Um, uh,
for her, she actually wrote in a letter
to her mother is a bit weird. She,
she was very obviously
her father's legacy,
um, as a genius, but
also as a genius who had,
um,
Brock basically sex and a danger to a,
into the world she said to herself,
but she felt she should redeem her
father's legacy by finding a way to poetry
and mathematics. Um,
which is an extra bar I,
and extraordinary, these strange thing.
But in externally, marvelous thing to say.
She said she wanted to create a
poetical science, which in the way,
if you think about it, po programming
is a sort of a poetical science.
It's a unifying and metaphor, um,
and logic, um, in a way that's,
that's very beautiful. So,
um, yeah, for her it was,
she felt that she had this,
this dark legacy that she had to redeem.
Um, and in terms of
identification, I don't know.
I could never have come up with this.
And in 15 years I'm not a soup.
Virginia's and I really felt that every
second is ed looking at this machine and
also lovely says paper, um, you know,
to make the leap from this
before, again, as I say,
logic at the time was still
basically Aristotelian, you know,
in terms of sentences. Um, and, and,
and syllogisms to look
at this machine and say,
there's gotta be a way to make logic
this perfect and this machine, like, um,
and then this machine could,
could compose music. I mean,
it's just a completely extraordinary
feat of imagination to see that in the
machine. Um, so yeah, I, I, um, yeah,
I'm just completely blown away by
their genius in and humbled by it.
Does that answer the question
in my reading about this?
I stumbled on something about,
I think they were a pair of
Swedish brothers actually
commercially made several
different engines and had customers for
them. Did you stumble on that as well?
Yeah,
I don't remember their name.
Oh,
the shirts I'm shoot,
I'm not sure if I've ever heard it
pronounced. I think it's shoots.
There were Swedish. Um,
uh, and actually, um, I,
I was delighted to see some,
I'm Swedish comics blog pop up when the
book came out saying as we all know the
difference, Sandra was actually built by
the famous Swedes, the shots for others.
Everyone has their own kind of national
history and the computer. Um, yeah,
they built the machine. They both are know
their own machine off of Babbage's, um,
arithmetic. Basically this method
of differences. Um, but they,
they had a completely different
mechanical system. Um, it's a bit,
when I saw one at the Science Museum,
I thought it was a model cause it's a
10th of the size or less than paviches
engine. Um, and there's, there is in
fact a beautiful video of it on Youtube.
If you look up shoots,
difference engine,
it'll come up cause I think
the Smithsonian has one
that they rent every once in
a while and it's just a, it's an
absolutely delightful little machine.
But as it turned out, it did
nobody really needed after all. So,
um, I don't think they made any
fortune off of it unfortunately.
Yeah.
There's one in I guess the astronomy
astronomical lab and u s spot one.
And uh, there was one in England
and I have one in Sweden I guess.
And everyone was like,
oh actually these are that useful.
It's quite sad actually.
I recall roughly
is a passing reference.
You must be a footnote for mathematics
would not only be too rigorous for the
spirit of a woman,
but also her constitution,
which seems obviously od to modern ears.
How many women mathematicians were there
f the time a loveless seems to have
been fairly well accepted as one,
but was it in fact an anomaly for
there to be a woman mathematician?
Was she seen as some sort of oddity or,
well, I mean what people tend
to see it as cute to be honest.
They tend to write, oh, you
know, isn't that adorable?
A woman trying to do mathematics and
the letter about her about mathematics
damaging and women's contents constitution
is actually from Augustus to Morgan.
Um, who wrote her mother saying twice
apparently saying, I'm, I'm very,
very concerned because,
um,
the lady Lovelace has as much
mathematical power as which challenged the
constitution of a man.
And you know,
somehow you felt that it was
overclocked for a woman's body. I mean,
this was actually a very
common idea. And he said, uh,
he gave me, he gave me some great
comic book dialogue. He said, soon,
the battle of the truth as soon as a
struggle between body and mind will begin.
Um,
and I mean it's,
it's actually incredibly sad and ironic
because the idea was that, um, Matt,
the mathematics,
the success of use of that part of the
brain with specifically damage women's
wounds, um, and lovelies did in
fact die of, of uterine cancer.
So, um, yeah, it was just, I can't
find anyone using that as proof.
I'm sure somebody somewhere
said I told you. Um, uh,
and actually Lovelace's um, mentor was
Mary Somerville. Um, certainly played up,
um, after whom Somerville
College and Oxford, his name,
she did all these very complicated
translations of works from the continent.
And I love this.
It was very definitely modeling herself
on Somerville and doing the translation
to the analytical engine, uh,
paper. Um, but Somerville,
um, I had to study in secret because her
parents thought she would hurt herself,
uh,
studying math and her,
I think her first husband didn't
agree with her studying math. So she,
she wrote her first mathematics
book when she was 45 when he died.
That's where she got her first freedom.
So no, it was very, very unusual.
I mean it was, this is kind
of at the end of that era. Um,
they started to have a women's
programs in college in 1870s,
1880s, and I think that's when
it started to turn around.
So we want to thank you for
all the amazing work you've
done to the great comic
and
the really beautiful book. Um,
but, uh, I've got to wonder like,
where are you heading now?
Like you said that you were sort of
ambushed by the comic and is there still
going to be a comic? I mean, I hope,
hi. I get this question a lot and
I'm here. I'm just kind of, um,
uh, I actually, I have not the proverbial
day job and I still work as an animator,
um, which is quite, uh,
all consuming work. Uh,
when it's on, I definitely have a
bunch more comics I'm dying to do.
I've got a ton of sketches, so
when work dies down a bit, I'll be,
I'll be cracking on for sure.
Yeah.
Um,
my understanding is that there
was a couple of critical problems,
maybe just one that needed
the difference engine. Uh,
back when Babbage was born,
computer was a job title.
It was the people who manually computed
tables of logarithms and they were full
of errors.
And this led to things like ships
sinking and it made just be that one
difference engine was enough
to solve that problem.
And there weren't any other problems.
Yeah. I mean this was kind of Babbage's
thing. The difference engine wasn't, yeah,
supposed to solve a specific calculation.
It was supposed to print out these big
tables because what would happen is you'd
have these giant books of every iteration
of a problem and then when you were at
sea without your difference engine or
in your accountant's office or whatever,
you would just go to volumes 15 and
pull it up and look up that one little
iteration. Um, but Babbage
himself actually, uh,
supervise this production of these,
you know,
beautifully triple checked error free
logarithm tables after which yeah,
you don't need anymore cause they're
all done. So that was um, yeah, the,
the difference engine was redundant
by the time, um, you know,
those tables were printed. So I
think for him it was more of an
he did,
he used to for a lot of stuff around
about all the problems that could solve,
but he was really more into just
building the engine itself. I think
what's happening to your
originals from the book?
Oh, hi. There are in fact no originals
from the book. It's completely drawn.
I in Photoshop, sorry. Yeah,
it's a virtual comic computer generated.
So if the point of the engine was to,
you know,
produce tables of numbers without areas
and he had 50 decimal digits precision,
did he ever work out how many
volumes wired to print that out?
I am quite sure he did Babbage with
her love working stuff like that out.
So I can't tell you specifically,
but I will tell you if it involves
working out and amount of a thing, um,
beverage,
you would have done it at some point.
Even under fixed plant.
You're talking about a lot of power.
Uh,
are there any other questions?
Hmm.
Okay. Well, let's thank our
guests. Thank you very much.